[Musique]
depuis l'adolescence pas un seul jour je
n'ai renoncé à cette conviction d'être
socialiste écrira à Pierre Mauroy la
preuve s'il le fallait à l'instant avec
ce portrait inédit signé par Caroline
béhagh disant après sa disparition
l'occasion de s'interroger maintenant
avec nos invités présents sur ce plateau
debadoc sur le parcours de celui qui fut
le premier Premier ministre de François
Mitterrand au lendemain du 10 mai 1980
Bernard Roman est avec nous bienvenue
Bernard Roman vous a vu témoigner dans
ce film vous êtes un vous étiez un
proche et même un très proche de Pierre
Mauroy à la mairie de Lille notamment au
sein du PS bien entendu vous avez aussi
été député du Nord c'était entre 1997 et
2016 avant de devenir le Président de
l'Autorité de régulation des transports
à vos côtés Michel cotta bienvenue à
vous Michel cotta c'est toujours un
plaisir de vous recevoir dans cette
émission vous êtes journaliste auteur
avec entre autres ce livre inscrit avec
votre compère Robert Namias le brun et
le rouge disponible chez Robert Laffont
vous avez avec Pierre Mauroy eu
l'occasion maintes fois de parler vous
l'avez longuement interviewé
à la toute fin de sa vie politique
d'ailleurs et on y reviendra bien
entendu avec vous durant cette émission
Frédéric saviki enfin avec nous
bienvenue vous êtes historien professeur
de sciences politiques très bon
connaisseur du Parti socialiste vous
enseignez à Paris impensé on Sorbonne et
vous êtes par ailleurs chercheur au sein
du Centre européen de sociologie et de
sciences politiques votre dernier livre
s'intitule la fin des parties avec un
point d'interrogation publié au presse
universitaire de France on va réécouter
si vous en êtes d'accord juste un
instant Pierre Mauroy nous sommes dans
la toute dernière ligne droite de la
présidentielle de 1980 les Français qui
ont ensuite vont se rassembler au second
tour sur le nom de François Mitterrand
ce seront des Français qui se
rassembleront non seulement sur le nom
de François Mitterrand mais également
sur ses orientations et ses propositions
ce ne sera pas la trahison ce sera la
clarté et la vérité
repasser ses extraits du film que nous
avons vu ensemble qui retraçaient
l'ensemble du parcours bien entendu de
Pierre Mauroy c'était aussi peut-être
rappelé ce qu'on ressent pas forcément
dans ce film mais il faut avoir vu une
seule fois à Pierre Mauroy en meeting
pour comprendre que c'était un une
formidable bête politique avec un
abattage formidable un tribunal comme on
en a plus beaucoup peut-être aujourd'hui
c'était aussi ça Bernard Roman Pierre
Mauroy
c'était un orateur parce que c'était un
homme vrai il avait le talent de d'un
orateur d'un grand orateur mais il
n'était jamais aussi bon dans les
meetings que quand il laissait de côté
les papiers qu'on lui avait préparé ou
qu'il avait préparé lui-même et qu'il
sentait le la foule le peuple le peuple
de gauche dont il parlait si bien qu'il
essayait de galvaniser dans les périodes
de campagne et notamment en 81 ça a été
un atout formidable pour François
Mitterrand qui en avait fait son
porte-parole alors que au sein du Parti
socialiste Pierre Mauroy était dans
l'opposition à François Mitterrand il
avait perdu le congrès de Metz deux ans
auparavant et François Mitterrand malgré
ça on fait son porte-parole et en en
faisant son porte-parole il finalement
il préampe un peu le rôle du Premier
ministre qui lui confiera une fois qu'il
sera élu en lisant un petit peu ce qui a
été écrit observé concernant Pierre
Mauroy
on peut constater que c'était un homme
qui aimait bien vivre il aimait bien
manger
c'est un homme robuste massif
cette convivialité m'amène à vous poser
cette question est-ce que le pire
Maurois publique qu'on a vu dans ce film
correspondait au pire mon roi privé que
vous avez bien connu c'était le même
homme ou pas
il était je vous ai dit que c'était un
homme vrai il était encore plus vrai
dans le privé que dans le public
c'était pas c'était pas un homme qui
aimait manger
il disait tout le temps ma mère me
disait on finit son assiette et donc il
finissait son assiette mais si on lui
donnait une petite assiette il mangeait
sa petite assiette et ce qui était
important dans un déjeuner ou un dîner
avec lui c'est pas ce qu'on mangeait
c'est ce qui se passait autour on
pouvait manger pendant une demi-heure et
avoir un déjeuner ou un dîner qui durait
trois heures ou 4 heures parce que on
parlait il refaitait le monde il s'est
un homme d'une conviction permanente de
social-démocrate qui voulait construire
des choses qui voulaient laisser des
choses que ce soit à Lille au niveau
régional au niveau national ou au niveau
du parti et il était toujours emporté
par par cette dynamisme qu'il avait en
lui Pierre Mauroy il aurait été le maire
de Lille pendant 28 ans entre 1973
et 2001
son surnom dans le Nord c'est gros
Quinquin est-ce que c'est un gentil
surnom dans le Nord gros quelqu'un c'est
très affectueux c'est très affectueux
parce que
le Quinquin c'est la chanson
traditionnelle des des Lillois des gens
du Nord dorment un petit Quinquin c'est
d'ailleurs une chanson qu'il reprend à
la tribune de la première réunion on
voit dans le documentaire la première
réunion qu'il fait à Lille à son retour
après avoir été nommé à Matignon il
chante avec
la joie qu'on lui a connu à ce moment-là
au milieu de des militants qui sont là
dorment un petit Quinquin et donc aucun
cas c'était très affectueux oui Michel
cotta alors c'est vrai qu'au lendemain
de la disparition de Pierre Mauroy
c'était le 7 juin
2013 vous avez publié un portrait de
Pierre Mauroy dans l'hebdomadaire Le
Point et vous dites ceci purement Roanne
pas comme essentiel souci de paraître
autrement qu'il était autre différence
avec bien des hommes politiques qui lui
ont succédé il n'était pas il n'a jamais
été avide de pouvoir et n'a jamais pensé
en se rasant ou pas à devenir président
de la République c'est un bon résumé de
ce qui était pour vous pire moment
on a tendance à résumé parce que c'est
résumé court c'est quelqu'un qui était
aussi je trouve qui était lui-même
lorsqu'il parlait à la tribune parce
qu'il y avait une partie de lui qui
était tellement dans son parti que
c'était naturel aussi et puis quelqu'un
qui ne se déguisait pas qui ne montrait
pas un autre visage alors justement
c'était ça qui rendait sa complicité
avec Mitterrand tout à fait étonnante
parce que autant là est compliqué autant
Pierre Mauroy jouer son jeu de
socialiste de gouvernement il y a
toujours voulu l'être il a été il a été
le premier il ne savait pas mentir
Pierre Mauroy c'est aussi ce que vous
dites le concernant
c'est ce qu'il disait maintenant
peut-être que c'est ce qu'il disait je
pense que je pense que c'est contraire
c'était contraire à son état d'esprit il
était quand il dit avec quelque chose à
dire il le disait y compris Mitterrand y
compris à Mitterrand et peu de gens
parlaient à Mitterrand comme il parlait
vous rappelez au moment justement de de
la rupture de la rigueur etc il est le
seul à avoir osé dire à François
Mitterrand ça moi je sais pas faire vous
voulez sortir de l'Europe ça moi je sais
pas je sais pas sans moi je ne sais pas
conduire une voiture sur le verglas
c'est ce qu'il avait dit à l'époque mais
il a dit à Mitterrand peu de gens
l'aurait dit comme ça donc mais il
n'avait pas le sentiment du pouvoir pour
le pouvoir et le pouvoir pour faire
quelque chose oui mais lui-même je me
rappelle avoir une conversation mais
tout le monde sans doute l'a eu avec lui
quand il aurait pu après tout se
présenter à la présence de la République
en 95 à la place de pierre de
il n'a pas voulu le faire moi il m'a dit
être Premier ministre c'est très bien
mais président non peut-être que vous ne
pouvez pas l'être mais en tout cas il le
disait avec sincérité où est-ce que vous
le situez Pierre Mauroy parmi les grands
responsables socialistes après 1969
après la naissance du Nouveau Parti
socialiste qui avait succédé à la sefio
vous le sud c'est où vous dans cette
hiérarchie des grands responsables
socialistes il fait partie on va dire
des quatre on va dire principaux leader
qui ont fait le socialisme le Nouveau
Parti socialiste dans les années 70 avec
Jean-Pierre Chevènement Michel Rocard
et François Mitterrand c'est-à-dire bon
alors après il y a eu une autre
génération qui est arrivée mais en fait
on pourrait ajouter aussi Gaston de fer
d'ailleurs qui a eu un rôle très
important notamment
en ralliant François Mitterrand au
fameux congrès d'Épinay en permettant
effectivement François Mitterrand de
devenir le premier secrétaire du Parti
socialiste mais surtout aussi de
d'orienter le Parti socialiste vers un
programme commun du nom de la gauche et
au fond jusqu'à la victoire donc c'est
un personnage très important parce que
il est quand même à l'époque le
représentant de la fédération du Nord
le Parti socialiste en 1900 la plus
importante du portefeuille
avec les Bouches-du-Rhône et le
Pas-de-Calais alors évidemment selon les
selon les moments mais enfin bon ils
sont à tous comme on dirait c'est à peu
près 10 entre 10 et 12000 adhérents donc
en 71 il y a peu d'adhérents encore aux
parties socialiste le Parti social se
construit essentiellement sur les bases
de la SFIO la convention des
institutions républicaines c'est
François Mitterrand mais il amène peu de
militants donc le parti ne va se
développer qu'après donc avoir le
soutien de Pierre Mauroy et Gaston deux
frères c'est central et il va apporter
une caution à François Mitterrand très
importante qui est là qui est la caution
symbolique quand même que représente le
nord c'est l'histoire dans l'histoire du
socialisme finalement il a su se rendre
incontournable d'une certaine manière
d'une des principales si ce n'est la
principale fédération tout ça c'est
construit en même temps parce que en
même temps qu'il incarnait le socialisme
du Nord il allait ensuite du coup
pouvoir
prendre la succession d'Augustin Laurent
la mairie de Lille il allait petit à
petit en quelque sorte être le
socialiste du Nord quoi donc fidèle à
ses racines et en même temps tourné vers
effectivement une nécessité de
modernisation donc il va il va incarner
ça Pierre Mauroy et apporter très
concrètement la politique c'est aussi
des soutiens militants de ce que
représente les mandats de la fédération
du Real politique ça c'est de la réelle
politique et et alors ce qui va apporter
aussi par la suite avant 1980 c'est que
c'est une des personnes qui va jouer un
rôle très important dans la dans
l'attraction vers le Parti socialiste
des chrétiens de gauche alors que que
Michel Rocard va symboliser d'une
certaine façon mais il est pas le seul
il y a aussi Jacques Delors il y a aussi
à la base plein de militants qui
viennent de la CFDT notamment qui était
avant au PSU et Pierre Mauroy qui alors
qu'il est pour dire l'héritier de la
SFIO qui était très laïcarde très
bouffeuse de curé il va lui bien
accompagner cette arrivée y compris à
Lille mais dans le Parti socialiste donc
c'est un homme qui a beaucoup compté
quand même dans l'attractivité du Parti
socialiste à cette époque là qui va
passer de quelques 80000 adhérents à pas
loin de 200000 à la fin de la Destiny 70
il va jouer ça et il va incarner
effectivement ce socialisme aussi
populaire quoi c'est très important il
est un des principaux finalement une des
principales figures ça se voit dans son
physique sa façon de s'exprimer mais il
représente un socialisme j'allais dire
ancré dans les classes populaires dans
le monde ouvrier dans une terre alors
c'était c'est lié à son parcours mais
c'est aussi sa capacité à incarner ça
qui avec des références récurrentes un
dans ses discours d'une part à Jean
Jaurès et d'autre part à Léon Blum
Pierre Mauroy François Mitterrand entre
les deux hommes
ça a été effectivement
parfois tendu on va y revenir qu'est-ce
que vous en diriez de ces relations
qui vient de dire Frédéric sa Viki l'un
des credos de Pierre Mauroy c'est le
rassemblement et le rassemblement des
socialistes d'abord il est contribue
largement à épiner Frédéric sady qui
vient d'évoquer il l'amplifie en 74 avec
l'arrivée des chrétiens des chrétiens
démocrates au sein du Parti socialiste
qui grossit encore le Parti socialiste
et il pense que il faut rassembler les
socialistes pour rassembler la gauche
pour gagner les élections
présidentielles
si
Pierre Mauroy est capable de faire ça
c'est parce que en 80 François
Mitterrand
gagne le congrès d'Épinay avec les
soutiens qu'on évoquait mais il ne veut
pas diriger le parti il ne veut pas
diriger le parti il en est le premier
secrétaire mais il veut pas mettre les
mains dans le cambouis et nomme un
secrétaire à la coordination et ce
secrétaire l'accord bien sûr Pierre
Mauroy qui va présider quasiment tous
les secrétariats nationaux tous les
bureaux nationaux du Parti Socialiste
François Mitterrand n'y venons
qu'exceptionnellement donc c'est lui qui
conduit le parti qui met en oeuvre cette
politique de rassemblement de
renforcement du parti dans les
départements et qui fait passer ce parti
de moins de 100.000 à 200 000 militants
et pour lui c'était essentiel parce
qu'il disait que le Parti socialiste
c'était toujours le cœur d'une campagne
et que plus ce cœur battait fort plus il
était important plus on se donnait des
chances d'élargir la masse de ceux qui
qui nous soutiendraient à propos de
cette relation entre les deux hommes
vous dites sur Pierre Mauroy il ne fait
pas partie des compagnons historiques de
François Mitterrand et n'avait pas pour
lui l'amour immodéré de ses amis
toujours contrairement à Mitterrand il
venait du socialisme et n'appartenait
pas à la bourgeoisie les deux hommes se
sont opposés frontalement car Mauroy ne
savait pas mentir mais il n'a pas connu
entre mais ils n'ont pas connu entre eux
le désamour oui c'est ça
à la période où évidemment après l'échec
de de François Mitterrand au
législatives de 78 c'est approché de
Rocard et d'ailleurs au fond là je l'ai
rapproché beaucoup de choses des
rapprochés le poids de le poids de
religieux enfin des catholiques dans le
parti beaucoup de choses irréprochaient
donc c'est lui-même il a beaucoup
discuté avec Michel Rocard ce qui a
fortement déplu à François Mitterrand
qui savait tout qui savait bien sûr
qu'ils se rencontrer dans quel bistrot
il sera rencontré tout ça bon tout ça ne
manquait à personne mais en revanche
elle a su un moment donné se dire moi je
peux pas revenir sur le programme en
commun moi j'ai signé le programme
commun Michel Rocard ne l'a pas signé
lui il peut aller où il veut moi je suis
obligé de me détacher et au fond c'est
le fait que au congrès de au congrès de
Metz ils se sont 1979 ils se sont
séparés et ça fait que mon Roi a une
très mauvaise prestation et sa motion a
eu très peu de voix mais en tout cas
c'est il a permis quelque part la
majorité à Mitterrand je ne suis pas sûr
qu'une ni à l'époque mon roi et Roca ne
l'aurait pas emporté j'en suis pas sûr
en tout cas leur prise de distance a
fait que Mitterrand a gagné le Congrès
avec Jean-Pierre Chevènement qu'il a
comme avec Gaston Defferre donc dans un
petit complot
ourdi en marge du congrès le lendemain
du 10 mai 1980 autrement dit le 11 mai
mon roi apprend et vous nous raconter
comment avec ce fameux téléphone dans la
voiture dans ce film mon roi apprend que
c'est lui qui committerrand a choisi
comme premier ministre pardon mais sauf
qu'il raconte dans ses mémoires que il
avait été prévenu par Mitterrand en
octobre alors voilà
juste après la chute de rencard juste
après le discours de Roca ou rencard a
échoué il a été prévenu à ce moment-là
quand François Mitterrand homme Pierre
Mauroy porte-parole de la campagne
présidentielle il le prédestine à cette
fonction et
je pense effectivement il a fait cette
confidence à Michel cotta que François
Mitterrand lui a dit mais il le garde
pour lui et la confirmation il attend
presque fébrilement le lendemain du 10
mai et c'est dans la voiture et que ce
Radiocom 2000 les téléphones portables
de l'époque que François Mitterrand
l'appelle et lui et lui confirme qu'il
choisit comme premier ministre Pierre
Mauroy c'est tardera très souvent
d'avoir mis en œuvre 96
propositions de François Mitterrand
Pierre Mauroy à Matignon François
Mitterrand à l'Elysée quels ont été pour
l'essentiel la relation les relations
entre les deux hommes alors c'était une
autre époque c'était à dire une époque
où quand même et en plus
particulièrement à gauche le Premier
ministre
c'était important c'est à dire que c'est
important symboliquement parce que ça
permettait de montrer qu'on rassemblait
l'ensemble des de la gauche et des
socialistes mais c'était important aussi
dans le gouvernement et et donc François
Mitterrand même si petit à petit
évidemment il va avoir tendance à
s'immiscer
dans pas mal d'affaires disons il est
quand même dans la dans la logique où il
est sa pierre Mauroy pas mal de
latitudes alors pas dans la composition
de tous les membres du gouvernement mais
enfin quand même en partie dans la
composition de son propre cabinet et
puis dans la conduite de la politique du
gouvernement donc
alors il va y avoir des des hauts et des
bas ou quelques années cross mais
globalement enfin juste en tout cas
l'affaire de 1984 qui va être le chèque
sur la loi
jusqu'à là disons il y a très très peu
de conflits ouverts en 1983 au fameux
entre guillemets tournant de la rigueur
lorsque se pose la question de sortir ou
pas du SME Pierre Mauroy et Jacques
Delors sont ouvertement contre cette
perspective proximité en hésite mais il
va quand même se rallier finalement à
l'hypothèse dominante en tout cas de
Matignon et donc Pierre Moreau va rester
il y a l'échec des élections municipales
de 83 où on pensait que Pierre Mauroy
allait être congédié il est maintenu en
place donc il y a quand même une
relation globalement qui est assez
j'allais dire harmonieuse en tout cas
plus harmonieuse que bien des relations
entre Premier ministre et président de
la République qu'on a pu connaître par
la suite donc c'est pas pour embellir
les choses mais on va dire quand même
que il y a globalement en quelque sorte
finalement assez peu de quoique ou en
tout cas de quoi être public même si
évidemment dans les arbitrages
l'Élysée peut intervenir mais
globalement on va dire ça c'est quand
même plutôt bien passé voilà jusqu'à
la fin qui sera beaucoup plus évidemment
difficile puisque pierre brosse vivra
assez mal quand même d'avoir été on va
dire remercier sur ce sur ce dossier
pour lequel il avait essayé justement
d'aller dans le sens d'une solution de
de compromis c'est-à-dire que la fameuse
synthèse il ne s'est sans doute pas
sentir responsable disons de l'échec de
la façon dont dans le débat c'était
déroulé sur le sur la question de
l'unification du service public d'accord
avec ce qui vient d'être dit
pour l'essentiel il est entre l'homme de
Matignon évidemment il était il était le
premier ministre de d'un gouvernement
d'union de la gauche et donc il avait un
rôle d'animateur que le président
n'aurait pas pu tenir et donc ça
renforçait encore ce rôle du premier
et ça a été une relation en plus Pierre
Mauroy avait toujours une une un immense
respect pour
le personnage de François Mitterrand et
donc ça se sentait dans leur relation de
travail
et je dois dire que sur 84 la fin
Pierre Mauroy l'attend plus mal ressenti
que tout ça ça s'est fait en deux jours
48 heures entre le moment où François
Mitterrand lui dit
je tiens bon et le moment où il nomme
Laurent Fabius il se passe 48 heures et
donc la pierre Morat ça c'est écroulée
sous lui quoi je veux dire et ça s'est
écroulé non pas sur son destin personnel
vous savez plus de 3 ans à Matignon
c'est compliqué déjà mais
parce que justement il avait essayé de
construire cette grande idée d'un
service public unifié de l'éducation
et que c'était une idée qui qui lui
tenait à cœur vraiment à cœur et donc il
a ressenti très très violemment ça pire
moment et son gouvernement Michel cotta
ont mis en place les mesures phares de
1980 sous la présidente Mitterrand alors
on va bien sûr citer les 39 heures de
travail hebdomadaire la 5e semaine de
congés payés l'abolition de la peine de
mort la décentralisation les
nationalisations les lois roulent la
retraite à 60 ans
mais finalement à la fin de sa vie il
avait l'air de dire que ce qui ce dont
il était le plus fier c'est qu'il avait
fait la preuve en étant à Matignon que
la gauche pouvait gouverner et vraiment
ça n'était pas donné tous les beaucoup
de stratégie de Jacques Chirac qui a été
quand même de faire battre Giscard
d'Estaing il pensait que Mitterrand en
aurait pour trois ans et qu'au bout de
trois ans lui à la tête de la majorité
la tête de l'opposition arriverait
la même chose ils ont donc pour deux ans
donc ce qui était formidable quand même
c'est que la machine s'est installée à
la grande surprise des huissiers de
Matignon d'ailleurs qui comprenaient pas
qu'ils soient là la nuit ils vont etc
mais la machine s'est installée et au
fond
à marcher sans chaos alors avec
évidemment des résultats électoraux tout
de suite très
il y a pas eu il y a pas eu de quoi qui
a pas eu d'articles dans les journaux
disons ces gens-là ne savent pas du tout
gouverner tout ce qu'on a tous ce qu'on
a lu depuis sur d'autres présidents de
la République donc ils ont fait quand
même la démonstration que oui il y avait
une gauche du gouvernement qui était
possible on va avoir un deuxième extrait
du film que nous venons de voir tout
cela se passe à Donna et nous sommes en
novembre 1982
j'ai été en classe
avec ce la mer ils sont laissés déroger
de l'usine foudroyée de Denain
est-ce que vous ne pensez pas que le
plus grand plaisir qui aurait été le
mien dans cette période
extraordinairement difficile c'était de
vous venir avec des brassés d'emploi il
y a personne
et pas surtout un gouvernement de gauche
qui doit laisser des usines ouvertes
si l'évolution de la technologie si
l'évolution du monde est-elle que ces
usines produiront des produits qu'on ne
pourra placer nulle part là et la triste
réalité
novembre
1982 Pierre Mauroy face aux ouvriers de
l'usine de Donna auquel il annonce la
fermeture de leur usine
Usinor en l'occurrence il fallait tout
de même un sacrin un certain courage
pour
s'adresser à ces ouvriers et leur
uniquement stipulé que leur usine allait
fermer c'est un tournant pour Pierre mon
moi alors il fallait énormément de
courage mais il faut quand même rappeler
que avant 1981 le Parti socialiste avait
beaucoup critiqué justement la
suppression des emplois dans la
serrurgie et une fois au pouvoir en 80
il y avait eu des annonces notamment
dans les mines également de maintien ou
de l'activité donc je vais dire que là
il faut effectivement doublement du
courage parce que c'est pas simplement
j'allais dire ce affronter ces électeurs
en face à face sur une
décision douloureuse mais c'est aussi
annoncé finalement un là pour le coup un
changement dans la politique qui a été
qui a été Pierre Mauroy
l'explique il le vit extrêmement
douloureusement mais c'est un symbole en
quelque sorte quand même de ce que les
socialistes doivent finalement découvrir
avec lequel ils doivent faire face une
fois aux commandes c'est que bon la
conjoncture internationale effectivement
est très très mauvaise ils avaient
anticipé une politique de relance de la
demande qui n'a pas eu l'effet escompté
et forcer effectivement d'accepter très
très douloureusement effectivement de
remettre en cause ces politiques qui
étaient de maintenir l'emploi industriel
alors ce qu'il faut quand même rappeler
parce que là le documentaire le mot de
passe c'est que j'ai dit à la décharge
de Pierre Mauroy c'est que ensuite quand
même les politiques d'accompagnement qui
vont être mises en place pour
accompagner la désindustrialisation et
la réindustrialisation d'une certaine
façon vont être quand même bien bien
plus importantes que ce qui aura été
fait par la suite dans d'autres à
d'autres moments donc évidemment on
ferme des usines mais en même temps on
va injecter beaucoup d'argent pour
permettre effectivement de combattre les
effets pas simplement sociaux mais
économique de cette perte d'emploi il
s'agit de faire passer la France du
secondaire au tertiaire c'était dit dans
ce documentaire je retiens
son bout de phrase où il dit surtout pas
la gauche ou surtout pas le Parti
socialiste parce que c'est une assez
bonne définition de social-démocratie
c'est exactement ça c'est Dieu sait
qu'on est les premiers concernés par le
travail des gens c'est ça qui veut dire
mais faire travailler des gens pour quel
cours sans avenir c'est condamner notre
politique condamnée au fond c'est une
découverte en marche d'une sociale
démocratie vous savez qu'il était
social-démocrate mais on s'appelait
socialiste à l'époque mais lui c'était
quand même la marche vers la sociale
démocratie qu'il a découverte à cette
occasion le politologue Rémi Lefebvre
dit que d'une certaine manière et
peut-être malgré lui mon roi aura
symbolisé cette gauche qui déçoit
souvent lorsqu'elle est au pouvoir je
dis un peu malgré lui parce que ça a été
un moment très dur pour lui donner un
larger a été aussi un moment très dur à
vivre pour Pierre Mauroy et il a assumé
cette rigueur
néanmoins est-ce que c'est pas aussi un
peu le symbole de cette gauche qui
déçoit son électorat la classe populaire
les classes populaires lorsqu'elle est
au pouvoir purement
c'est le symbole de la modernité je le
dis avec force de la modernité d'une
conception de la sociale démocratie et
il l'a montré avec le tournant de la
rigueur il l'a montré à Denain en disant
ce qu'il dit en disant mais
certes on est de gauche certes vous êtes
mes frères de combat certes vous êtes
une priorité pour moi mais si on laisse
ouvert cette chirurgie ça finira par
fermer vous serez tous au chômage autant
et troisièmement Pierre Mauroy est
moderne parce que il dit j'ai une dette
envers vous j'ai une dette envers tous
ceux qu'on met sur le carreau parce
qu'on ferme la sidérurgie et c'est ce ce
grand élan qu'il a donné à la région
Nord-Pas-de-Calais par la suite qui a
été relayé par d'autres à la tête de la
région qui fait qu'aujourd'hui la région
du Nord-Pas-de-Calais est une région qui
se développe qui a un centre
un centre tertiaire extrêmement
dynamique à Lille avec Euralille qui est
le bébé de Pierre Mauroy et qui rayonne
sur l'ensemble de la région qui était
une façon pour dire mon roi de dire ce
qu'on ne peut plus faire sur le secteur
secondaire
quoi que on en fait encore sur le
secteur secondaire avec l'automobile on
va le faire avec cette grande turbine
tertiaire que je veux créer à Lille et
il a créé à Lille ça signifie aussi une
certaine acceptation de l'économie de
marché c'est ce fameux
passage d'après 83 et c'est Laurent
Fabius qui incarnera ce passage mais
associal démocratie accepte l'économie
de marché donc on peut pas dire qu'ils
prennent les gens en traître mais
évidemment c'est difficile de toute
façon les records en version sont
toujours difficiles qu'on soit à gauche
ou qu'on soit à droite alors peut-être
que c'est plus facile pour un
gouvernement de droite de fermer une
usine mais j'en suis pas sûr mais de
toute façon il y a des il y a vraiment
des décisions qu'il faut prendre si on
est au pouvoir on peut décevoir la
catégorie des gens auxquels on s'adresse
mais faut la remplacer par une catégorie
qui vous soutient si on n'arrivera à la
remplacer par une vous soutient ces
choses ça marche ça marche pas longtemps
il nous reste trois minutes la déception
est aussi à la mesure des attentes qui
avaient été créé en 80 et avant 80
d'abord parce que le Parti socialiste la
gauche avait été écarté du pouvoir
pendant 23 ans parce qu'il y avait la
pression quand même la partie communiste
qui est restée quand même un partenaire
de poids équivalent du Parti socialiste
malgré les progrès du Parti socialiste
et que donc évidemment Pierre Mauroy en
80 et l'ensemble du gouvernement ouvre
des espoirs voilà alors il y a des
réalisations dont on a rappelé
effectivement l'importance mais il y a
aussi beaucoup d'attentes par rapport au
chômage par rapport à la
désindustrialisation qui a commencé dans
la deuxième moitié des années 70 et là
évidemment bah ils vont être obligés
j'allais dire de décevoir et ils vont
décevoir d'autant plus que ils avaient
quand même beaucoup trop promis
probablement et là c'est pas la faute de
Pierre Mauroy seul bien évidemment et il
a même d'ailleurs plutôt lui on l'a
rappelé au Congrès essayer de tempérer
les ardeurs très
voudrait dire socialiste dans un seul
pays qui était incarné par Jean-Pierre
Chevènement et que François Mitterrand
va reprendre à son compte donc il a été
il a porté ça mais d'une certaine façon
il était plus probablement conforme à ce
qu'il était j'allais dire après 82-83
qui ne l'était en 80 alors on apprend
dans ce documentaire il nous reste deux
minutes par mois simplement une chose
parce que ça ceux qui nous regardent ne
le savait probablement pas
l'Hôtel Matignon la présidence de
République c'était pas forcément le
grand rêve depuis un moment le grand
rêve depuis un mois c'était de devenir
le premier secrétaire du Parti
socialiste
bon qu'est-ce qu'on peut dire de ce
passage de Pierre Mauroy à la tête du
Parti socialiste entre 88 et janvier 92
est-ce que c'était pas le plus mauvais
moment pour prendre la tête de ce parti
socialiste alors qu'il s'agissait
d'organiser la succession de François
Mitterrand et sans doute un mauvais
moment un mauvais moment mais Pierre
Mauroy pour lui c'était le Graal premier
secrétaire du Parti socialiste qui il
était socialiste on n'a pas dit qu'avant
1981 il était quand même secrétaire
général des Jeunesses socialistes et
donc tout jeune se reconnaissait dans
ses ouvriers qui partaient tous les
matins prendre le train de l'acide
chirurgie justement des chirurgistes
et pour lui c'était quelque chose
d'essentiel et ce qu'il a fait à la tête
du Parti socialiste je trouve de ce
point de vue là que faut pas être
injuste
la première chose qu'il a fait c'est
qu'il a créé un hebdomadaire qui a été
diffusé à 300 000 exemplaires RA
simplement élargissement les
sympathisants les militants tous les
vendredis il recevaient un abdomadaire
qui s'appelait vendredi la deuxième
chose qu'il a faite c'est le congrès de
l'arche qu'il était je vous invite à
relire ce congrès le texte de ce congrès
c'était le bad cutterberg français
c'est-à-dire l'inscription de la
démarche du Parti socialiste dans
l'économie de marché dans la sociale
démocratie et puis je veux dire une
chose quand même
est-ce que la gauche je conclue là
dessus mais je dirais plus rien derrière
est-ce que la gauche déçoit quand elle
est au pouvoir la gauche gagnant 81 en
86 il y a des élections législatives à
la proportionnelle le Parti socialiste
fait le score le plus haut de son
histoire en 1986 il a gouverné 5 ans
alors certes on peut dire qu'il a déçu
mais il fait 32% au niveau national le
Parti socialiste donc il n'a pas des ça
fait rêver aujourd'hui quoi ça en fait
rêver certains 32% bon ça sera le mot de
la fin merci vraiment à tous les trois
d'avoir rendu hommage à notre manière à
Pierre Morrois disons après la
disparition de l'ancien Premier ministre
et grand personnage on l'a dit du Parti
socialiste vos réactions ça sera sur
hashtag débat doc sur Twitter merci
aussi à sel massali qui comme à
l'accoutumée m'a aidé à préparer cette
émission et je vous retrouverai tout
simplement pour un prochain débat doc ça
sera bien sûr avec son documentaire et
son débat à très bientôt
[Musique]